hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor biochemistry microbiology and
immunology these are topics that I am
really excited about I love learning
about them and I want you to love
learning about them too I have a
background in these topics so you'll
find videos on biochemistry microbiology
and immunology on biology professor
they're also going to be videos on a
wide range of topics in biology for
example introductory biology for those
beginners out there also cell biology
genetics evolutionary biology ecology
these are all things that I'm excited
about and I want to share them with you
so take a look at my videos you will
find that they cover a range of
information however there might be
something that you're interested in
learning about that I don't have yet if
that's true then feel free to leave
comments or questions below and maybe
those topics are ones that I can get to
in the future
but for now welcome to biology professor
I hope you learn a lot and I hope you
have fun too
so let's get started